CASEY RODRIGUEZ: OK.
So let's continue our discussion
of continuity, which we began
last time, which is--
which I defined last time,
and I wrote again here,
which intuitively says
that if you want to be--
that if x is sufficiently
close to number c,
then f of x will be
very close to f of c.
So it connects how
the function behaves
near a point to how a
function behaves at the point.
And last time, we
gave an example
of a function
which is continuous
everywhere, namely the function
f of x equals ax plus b,
and one that was not
continuous at a point c.
And we ended with--
let me just recall the
question I asked last time.
If f is a function-- let's say
that its whole domain is r.
Does there exist a point
where it's continuous?
Now, I could answer
this question now just
using the definition, but
I'll answer it in a minute
after we prove the
following theorem, which
is an analog of this theorem
that we proved here for limits.
We showed that if
you have a subset
s of r, a cluster
point of s-- so this
is where you take limits,
and then the limit
as x goes to c of
f of x equals l
if and only if, for every
sequence converging to c,
we have f of xn, which is a
new sequence, converges to l.
So this connects
limits of functions
to limits of sequences-- limits
along sequences, if you like.
We're going to prove an
analog of this theorem
now for the notion
of continuity.
But there's kind of--
and these two definitions
certainly look--
if you look at the
definition of limit
and the definition
of continuity,
this one certainly looks
like the definition of limit
where now the limit has to be
f of c, the function evaluated
at that point.
And it essentially is, but we
do have a degenerate case where
c here is not required to
be a cluster point of s.
It's just any point of s.
And we'll have two cases,
c is a cluster point of s
and c is not a
cluster point of s.
And you'll see that when c
is not a cluster point of s,
we'll have a silly situation
for talking about continuity.
So this is the following A
theorem, which has three parts.
So suppose s is a subset of r.
c is an element of s.
f is a function from s to r.
So the first part is if c
is not a cluster point of s,
then f is continuous at c.
So if we're looking at
continuity at a point,
the only interesting
points to look at
are cluster points of the set s.
Otherwise, no matter
what function it is,
it will be continuous
at such a point.
The second is that--
now let's suppose we're in
the more interesting case
that c is a cluster point of s.
Suppose c is a
cluster point of s,
which is essentially the
only thing that doesn't--
that's missing from this
definition and the definition
for limit.
Then f is continuous at c.
And this is borne
out in this theorem
if and only if the limit
as x goes to c of f of x
equals f of c.
And the third part
of this theorem,
which is now the analog of
this theorem we proved here
for limits, is the following--
f is continuous at c if and
only if for every sequence
xn of elements of s such
that x of n converges to c,
we have f of x sub n
converges to f of c.
So again, if c is not a
cluster point of the set,
then every function is going
to be continuous at that point.
So this is kind of a--
so if c is not a
cluster point of s,
this is a silly case to look at.
All right.
So let's prove the
first theorem--
I mean, the first
part of this theorem.
So what's the intuition?
Remember, continuity
is a connection
between f near a point and
the function at the point.
Now, if the only points
near c is c, then
f of x equals f of c for x
near c because x can only be c.
And therefore, that will
be less than epsilon.
So when we're at a point
that's not a cluster point,
it kind of removes
the near part.
And we're just looking at f at c
and comparing f to itself at c.
So let's suppose f is
not a cluster point.
So we want to prove
continuity, so that's a
for all epsilon delta argument.
So let epsilon be positive.
Since c is not a cluster point
of s, what does this mean?
So remember, to
be a cluster point
of a set s means for all
delta positive, there exists--
so let me recall what
it means to be a cluster
point over here on the side.
So c is a cluster point of s.
This means for all delta
positive, the set x minus delta
x plus delta
intersect c, intersect
s takeaway c is not empty.
So since c is not
a cluster point,
that means there
exists some delta 0 so
that this interval is disjoint
from s takeaway c such
that c minus delta
0, c plus delta
0 intersect s takeaway
c equals the empty set.
Now, if I include c
in this intersection--
so another way of stating
this is that the only thing--
since c is an element
of s, the only thing
that's in this
intersection is c.
So this here is the
rigorous way of saying
there's nothing in s near
c except for c itself.
And therefore, there's
nothing to compare to f of c.
So we'll choose delta to be
this one because then there's
nothing--
there's no x in s in this
interval other than c.
And then f of c
minus f of c is 0,
so choose delta to be delta 0.
And if x minus--
so now we want to say
that this delta works.
So if x is in s and x
minus c is less than delta,
that implies x equals c.
Because the only thing in this
interval that's coming from s
is c.
And therefore, f
of x minus f of c--
this is equal to f
of c minus f of c
equals 0, which is
less than epsilon.
So this is a really
degenerate case
of when you're trying
to see if a function is
continuous at a certain point.
All right.
So let's now move to the
more interesting part
that sees a cluster point.
So suppose c is a
cluster point of s.
And we want to show f is
continuous at c if and only
if the limit of f as x goes
to c of f of x equals f of c.
Going this direction
is really quite easy,
so we're going to
go this direction.
And you should be able to
prove this direction just
from what I write down here.
So suppose the limit as x goes
to c of f of x equals f of c.
I mean, this whole
argument is kind of silly
because the definitions are
just so close except for now c
is a cluster point,
so that's not
missing from either definition.
But the only difference is this
guy, you only look at x near c
but not at c.
So suppose the limit as x goes
to c of f of x equals f of c.
Now we want to show
that f of x is--
that f is continuous at c,
so let epsilon be positive.
Since we have this, there
exists a delta positive such
that if x is in s and the
absolute value of x minus c
is bigger than 0 is
less than delta 0,
then f of x minus f of
c is less than epsilon.
And we'll just choose
delta to be this delta 0.
If x minus c is less than delta
0, then there are two cases.
Either x is equal to c
or x is not equal to z.
See?
So let's write it this way.
If x equals c, then
clearly, f of x minus f of c
equals f of c minus f of c
equals 0 is less than epsilon.
And if x is not equal to c, then
that's certainly bigger than 0,
but we're still assuming
it's less than delta,
which remember, is this
delta 0 coming from the fact
that the limit as x
goes to c of f of x--
I missed that there--
tells me that this
is less than epsilon.
So it just follows immediately
from the definition.
There's not much to it.
OK.
So now let's prove the third
part of this theorem, which
is an analog of that theorem
we have over there for limits.
So let's prove this direction.
Let's suppose f is
continuous at c,
and now we want to prove this
statement about sequences.
So let me also--
when I prove the
opposite direction,
not have to label it.
So let me put a star.
This star is going to
be the right-hand side
of this statement.
So let x sub n be a sequence
in s of elements of s such
that x converges to c.
Now, I drew this
picture for limits,
and it's the same
picture now for this guy.
And we're wanting to show
now that the limit as n
goes to infinity of f of
x sub n equals f of c.
So here's the
epsilon m argument,
so let epsilon be positive.
So now I'll go to the picture.
Here's f of c.
Here's f of c plus epsilon,
f of c minus epsilon.
So what do we know?
We know the function
is continuous at c.
So that means that
if I look at c, then
there exists a delta so that
if I'm in this interval here,
everything in this interval
gets mapped to inside
of this interval.
Now, what else do I know
or what else am I assuming?
x sub n is a sequence
converging to s.
So for large n, for n big
enough for some capital M0,
x sub n is going to lie
inside this interval.
If you like, in the definition
of convergence of a sequence,
epsilon is equal to
delta in that definition.
But don't mind that.
So for all n big enough, x
sub n lies in this interval.
And since this
interval gets mapped
inside this interval
by f, this f of x
sub n will end up in this
interval within epsilon
to f of c as long
as n is big enough.
And so this picture I just went
through, this is the proof.
And now we just need
to write it out.
Since f is continuous
at c, there
exists a delta positive
such that if x minus c is
less than delta, this
tells me f of x minus f
of c is less than epsilon.
Now, since the sequence
x sub n converges to c,
there exists some
integer capital M0
such that for all n bigger
than or equal to 0, x
sub n minus c is
less than delta.
And therefore, for all n bigger
than or equal to m sub 0,
f of x in will be within
epsilon of f of c.
So this will be the m we choose.
Then if n is bigger
than or equal to M,
we get that x sub n minus x
minus c is less than delta,
which implies by how
delta's defined--
if x minus c is within distance
delta, f of x minus f of c
is within distance epsilon.
We get f of x sub n minus f
of c is less than epsilon.
So that gives us one direction.
All right.
So now we'll prove the
opposite direction.
So we're assuming that this
statement star holds, namely
for all sequence x
sub n's converging
to c, we have f of x sub
n converging to f of c.
And we want to prove
that the limit or that f
is continuous at c.
And we're going to do this
by contradiction, which
is the same way we proved
the opposite direction
for the theorem about limits.
So the proof is by
contradiction, namely
suppose the conclusion
we want does not hold.
So suppose f is not
continuous at c.
So let me recall we negated that
definition in the last lecture,
but we'll negate it again.
For this, this means that
there exists a bad epsilon
so that for all delta
positive, there exists an x
and s satisfying x minus
c is less than delta.
And f of x minus f of c
is bigger than or equal
to epsilon 0.
All right.
So since we're assuming
f is not continuous
or exists at epsilon
0, so we have all this,
which holds for every delta.
And now we'll choose delta
to be 1, 1/2, 1/3, and so on.
Then there exists
x sub 1 in s such
that x sub 1 minus
c is less than 1
and f of x sub 1 minus f of c is
bigger than or equal to epsilon
0.
That's just delta.
If you like delta, equals 1.
And now we continue.
There exists x
sub 2 in this such
that x sub 2 minus
c is less than 1/2.
And so here, this
is delta equals 1/2.
So this is delta
equals 1/2, and so on.
So then we conclude--
so if you like, omit
this from the proof.
And this is really what's
behind the next statement
I'm about to make.
Then for all natural
numbers n, there
exists an x sub n in s such that
x sub n minus c is less than 1
over n, and f of x
sub n minus f of c
is bigger than or
equal to epsilon 0.
Now let's take a look
at this sequence.
We're trying to break something.
And we'll end up breaking
the star assumption.
So now we have this
sequence, x sub n
of s, which we're getting
closer and closer to c.
So we have 0 is bigger than
or equal to x sub n minus
c is bigger--
is less than 1 over n.
So this converges to 0.
This converges to 0.
So by the squeeze theorem,
the absolute value
of x sub n minus
c converges to 0.
And therefore, x sub
n converges to c.
By squeeze theorem, we get
that xn converges to c.
Now, since we're
assuming star holds--
that's the right side of
3, of the if and only if--
it must be the case that f
of xn converges to f of c.
That's what star
tells me-- that if I
take a sequence converging to
c, f of x converges to f of c.
But each one of
these, remember, is
bigger than or equal to epsilon
0, which is a contradiction.
Epsilon 0 is a positive number.
And that concludes the
proof of this theorem.
That gives us an equivalent
way of stating continuity
in terms of sequences.
And just like for
limits, this will
allow us to use what we know
about sequences to conclude
analogous facts for
continuous functions.
So let's look at a
non-trivial example
of a continuous function
and also put this theorem
to use, this previous theorem.
The functions f of x equals sine
x and g of x equals cosine x,
these are continuous functions.
So meaning their domain is
the set of real numbers,
so they're continuous
at every real number.
They're continuous at c
for every c, a real number.
So we're going to use this--
well, we're not going to
use this theorem just yet
on this part.
We're actually going to prove
sine is continuous directly
from the epsilon delta
definition, which is always
good.
So first, we claim sine x.
So before I say what
we're going to do,
let me just give you
a quick refresher
on what you can prove just
from the definition of sine
and cosine.
Remember, I'm not--
I would usually put this to
the class and see who remembers
and who doesn't.
So this is also supposed to
be a unit circle, although it
doesn't quite look like that.
Remember that sine and cosine
are defined as you travel along
signed distance x
along the circle,
and you arrive at a point on
the unit circle, which you--
so it's an ordered pair.
The first element
you call cosine x.
The second element
you call sine x.
So that's how sine
of x is defined.
So now simply--
I'm not going to do this because
this is trig, not analysis.
But from the definition
of sine and cosine
from the unit circle,
we have that, of course,
all x and r sine x plus cosine
squared x is equal to 1.
And therefore, each of
these individual things
has to be less than or
equal to 1, which upon
taking square roots means that--
so you have these.
Now, you can also make a
better estimate for sine x
when x is close to 0, which is
only useful for x close to 0,
but which is the
following-- that for all x,
sine x is less than or equal to
the absolute value of x, just
obtained by comparing the
length of one side of a triangle
from this picture with
the length of the arc.
So you have this,
and then you also
have the angle
sum formula, which
says that sine of a plus
b equals sine a cosine b
plus cosine a sine b.
And you also have the--
I can't remember the name
of the exact formula.
I think it's difference to
product or something of that
nature, which says sine of a
minus sine a b, you can write--
so this is using the
previous formula--
twice sine of a minus b over
2 cosine of a plus b over 2.
So using these elementary
properties of sine and cosine,
we'll now show that
sine of x is continuous.
So first thing we want
to show is that sine x
is a continuous function.
So let's see.
In R, we're going to show
sine is continuous at c.
Let epsilon be positive.
And now we have to say
how to choose delta
depending on this epsilon.
Choose delta to be epsilon.
Now we'll use these
elementary properties
to show that this delta works.
Then if x minus c
is less than delta,
we now want to show that f of x
minus f of c, sine x minus sine
c, is less than epsilon.
So sine x minus sine
c, this is equal to--
by this last formula we
have on the board over here,
this is equal to
twice sine x minus c
over 2 cosine x plus c over 2.
And now this is the product
of 2 times the absolute value
of sine times absolute
value of cosine.
By the second
property over here,
cosine is always bounded
by 1, so this is less than
or equal to 2 times the absolute
value of sine x minus c over 2.
And now we use this
third property here
that sine x is less than or
equal to the absolute value
of that thing
you're sticking in.
So this is less than or equal
to 2 times x minus c over 2,
which equals x minus c.
So now we're in business.
We've connected f
of x to x minus c.
So this is less than
or equal to-- so this
is less than delta, which equals
epsilon by our choice of delta.
And therefore, sine x minus
sine c is less than epsilon.
Sine x minus sine c
is less than epsilon.
So thus, function sine
x is continuous at c.
Now we'll use this and the
theorem we showed a minute ago.
Have I erased it?
Yes, I have now
officially erased it.
Anyways, we used
the previous theorem
that we proved for the
equivalence of continuity
and convergence of sequences to
show that cosine is continuous.
So let c be an
element of R. Let xn
be a sequence converging to c.
And we now want to show
that cosine of x sub n
converges to cosine of c.
Once we've done that,
then by the theorem
we proved previously,
we can conclude
that cosine is continuous at c.
Now, here's the thing.
For all x and r,
we have cosine of x
is equal to sine of
x plus pi over 2.
We can deduce that simply
from this angle sum formula.
Take a equals c, b
equals pi over 2.
I'm using that cosine
of pi over 2 is 0.
And this is what we'll use,
and the fact that we know sine
is continuous.
Since the sequence
xn converges to c,
this implies the sequence x
sub n plus pi over 2 converges
to c plus pi over 2.
Now, this sequence x sub
n plus pi over 2 converges
to this number.
And since sine is
continuous, we have
by the previous theorem that
sine of this converges to this.
And therefore, cosine of--
cosine of x sub n, which
is equal to sine of x sub n
plus pi over 2, converges to
sine of c plus pi over 2, which
equals cosine of c, i.e.
cosine of x sub n
converges to cosine of c.
And therefore, we've now shown
that cosine is also continuous.
So let's answer this
question real quick.
So the answer is no.
You can find a function
which is discontinuous
at every point,
every real number.
So maybe this is an example
rather than a theorem,
but I'll state it as a theorem.
Let f of x be the function
which takes the value
1 if x is irrational, 0
if x is not irrational.
Then f is not continuous
at every c and r.
So first off, don't
try to plot this
using Matlab or
Mathematica or anything
because first off,
computers can't
deal with irrational numbers.
So you will just get 1 no
matter what you stick into f.
OK.
So you have this function,
which is 1 if x is a rational 0.
If x is not a rational
number, if it's irrational,
let's show it's
discontinuous at every c.
A different way, if you like,
to state the theorem which
I've already erased--
but let me just state
it slightly differently.
f is not continuous at c.
So remember, the two
statements are equivalent if
and only if their
negations are equivalent.
So f is not continuous
at c if and only
if there exists a sequence
x sub n such that xn
converges to c and f of xn--
the sequence fn of xn does
not converge to f of c.
So maybe it just
doesn't converge at all,
or maybe it converges to
something other than f of c.
So this is just a restatement
of the theorem we've already
proven but now using negations
of the statements that
appeared on the if and only if.
So there's two cases
to consider for this.
So now we're going--
so this is a statement of
the theorem that we're--
a restatement of the
theorem we're using.
And now we're going to prove the
theorem that I've stated here.
So let c be an
element of R. We're
going to show that this
function is discontinuous at c.
There are two cases to
consider, c is a rational number
or c is an irrational number.
So case 1-- c is
a rational number.
Let's show f is not
continuous at c.
Now, we know that for
every natural number n,
there exists an element x sub
n and the complement of q,
so an irrational number, such
that c is less than x sub n
is less than c plus 1 over n.
So we proved this
in an assignment.
Between any two
real numbers, I can
find a rational number,
an irrational number
in between them.
So that's what this statement
says, is for each n,
I can find an irrational
number between the number c
and the number c plus 1 over n.
Now, by the squeeze
theorem, this
is just a constant sequence,
if you like, converging to c.
This convergence to c.
And as n goes to infinity,
this convergence to c.
So I get that the sequence
x sub n converges to c.
This will be my bad sequence
to satisfy this conclusion
because--
so xn converges to c,
but if I look at f of xn,
if I take the limit as n
goes to infinity of f of xn,
since all the xn's
are not rational--
they're irrational numbers--
and I stick them
into f, I get 0.
And this does not
equal 1, which equals
f of c because we're in the case
that c is a rational number.
So here we use the
density of the irrationals
to show that this
function is not
continuous at a rational
number, and we'll
do the same thing for the case
that c is an irrational number.
It's the same
proof, except now we
essentially take compliments.
We proved this theorem right
after the Archimedean property
of r that for any
two real numbers,
I can find a rational
number in between them.
So for every n, there exists
a rational number such
that c is less than x of n
is less in c plus 1 over n.
And again, by the
squeeze theorem,
it follows that
xn converges to c.
And if we look at
the limit as n goes
to infinity of f
of x of n, this is
equal to-- all of these
values are 1, which does not
equal 0, which equals f of c.
And c is assumed to be
an irrational number.
So this function
is not continuous
at every real number.
So just terminology here.
If you hear me say
this, when I say
something is not continuous,
I'll often say discontinuous.
OK.
We're going to
use this theorem--
I keep saying this although
I already erased it,
but the theorem that
equates continuity
at a point and the fact that
every sequence converges--
every sequence converging to
c implies f of xn converges
to f of c.
We're going to use that theorem
to get corresponding theorems
about continuity that look
analogous to statements
we made about sequences.
And then we'll consider a
case which is not covered,
which has no analog
for sequences.
So let me state the
following theorem.
So suppose s is a subset
of r, c is an element of s.
And I have two
functions from s to R.
Then if f and g are
continuous at c,
then the conclusion
is f plus g--
the function f plus
g is continuous at c.
f times g is continuous at c.
And if g of x does not
equal 0 for all x and s,
so I can divide by it, then
f over g is continuous at c.
And so for example, I'll
prove the first statement,
the other two, you can
prove for yourself.
And again, this just follows
from this characterization
we have of a function being
continuous at a point in terms
of limits of sequences.
And limits of
sequences we know well.
We've proven all these
properties about them.
If you like, that's where
we did all the hard work.
And now getting
some payoff in that
we get interesting statements
without a whole lot of work.
So we're assuming f and
g are continuous at c,
so let's prove f plus
g is continuous at c
via this sequential
characterization.
Suppose xn is a sequence
converging to c.
Then since f and g
are continuous at c,
this implies that
the sequences f
of x sub n converges to
f of c, and g of x sub n
converges to g of c.
And therefore, by the theorem
we proved several lectures ago
that the sum of two
convergent sequences
converges to the
sum of the limits,
you get that f plus g of x
sub n, which is f of x sub n
plus g of x sub n, converges to
f of c plus g of c or function
f plus g evaluated at c.
And that's it.
We've now shown that
every sequence converging
to c, f plus g of x sub n
converges to f plus g of c.
And similarly for the others,
although there's maybe
a little bit of a small hiccup
here in that you want to--
well, no.
So this follows--
I was thinking of
something else.
Don't worry about that.
But 2 and 3 also
follow similarly
using the sequential--
the analogous
sequential theorems.
However, we do have--
so these are three
natural operations
we can do with two functions.
We can add them.
We can multiply them.
We can divide them, just
like we had for sequences.
There is one operation
we can do with functions
that you don't do with sequences
or can't do with sequences,
and that's compose them.
So the natural question
is, is the composition
of two continuous
functions continuous?
And the answer to that is yes.
We have to state this carefully.
So suppose a and b are a subset
of R, and c is an element of a.
So let's write this a
little bit differently.
Let a and b be a subset of
r. c is an element of a,
and f will be a function from--
let me get this right.
f will be a function
from a to r,
and g is a function
from a set b to a.
OK.
So I'm getting this backwards.
So when I compose these two,
when I take f of g, f of g
will be a function
now from b to r.
So if g is continuous at c and
f is continuous at the point
g of c, which is,
remember, an element
of a, then the composition
f of g is continuous at c.
So we'll use, again,
this characterization
in terms of sequences.
We don't necessarily have to.
We could have done it, strictly
speaking, from the definition.
But this is a nice short way
of proving this statement.
So let xn be a sequence in
b, so of elements of b such
that x sub n converges to c.
And what we want to show
is that f of g limit
as n goes to infinity of f of g
of x sub n equals f of g of c.
Let me put this off to the side.
OK.
So since xn converges to c
and g is continuous at c,
this implies that the sequence
g of xn converges to g of c.
Now, g of x sub n--
this is a sequence now in a
converging to an element of a.
Yeah?
So since this sequence g of
x sub n converges to g of c
and g, and now f, is
continuous at g of c,
this implies that f of g
of x sub n converges to f
of g of c, i.e., this is, by
definition, the same as saying
f of g of x sub n
equals f of g of c.
So we have an operation that
we can't do with sequences,
but this operation still
preserves continuity.
So taking sums of
continuous functions
maintains a continuous--
stays in the class of
continuous functions.
The product of two continuous
functions is continuous.
The quotient is continuous.
And now also the composition
of two continuous functions
is continuous.
So as a consequence of this,
we can use this to prove some--
give more examples of
functions which are continuous.
So for example, for all
n, a natural number,
f of x equals x to the n
is continuous as a function
for x and r.
So what's the proof?
We can do this by induction.
So for n equals 1, f of x
equals x, we've already done.
That was one of
the first examples
of continuous functions
we did, was ax plus b.
So a equals 1, b equals
0 gives me this case.
So this is the base case.
Let's now do the inductive step.
Suppose that the function
x to the m is continuous.
And now we want to show x to
the n plus 1 is continuous.
Then x to the m plus 1, this
is equal to x times x to the m.
And since x to the
m is continuous
and the function f of x
equals x is continuous,
the product of two continuous
functions is continuous.
It's a product of two continuous
functions, which by the theorem
we proved implies that x to
the n plus 1 is continuous.
So I keep saying continuous,
but what I'm saying is for all c
and r, x to the m
is continuous at c.
So maybe I should have
written that down,
but I think that meaning
should be clear enough.
And by the same
inductive reasoning,
you could also prove that in
a natural number, polynomials
are continuous. f of x--
for all in a natural
number, a0 and R,
the function given by a
polynomial a sub n x to the n
plus a sub n minus 1, x to
the n minus 1 plus a sub 0
is continuous.
So rather than write down the
actual proof by induction,
let's talk our way through it.
So again, for n
equals 1, this is just
going to be some number times
x, which we've already dealt
with in a previous example.
So we know that's continuous.
So that settles the base case.
Now let's assume that
we've proved this for n
equals m, or let's assume
this for n equals m
and look at a function
with n equals n plus 1.
That's going to be a to
the a sub m plus 1 times x
to the n plus 1 plus a
lower-order polynomial, which
we already know is continuous.
And a sub m plus
1 times x to the n
plus 1, that's
continuous because it's
the product of a constant
and a continuous function
by the previous example.
So that would be continuous
plus the lower order
polynomial, which is
continuous by assumption.
That will be continuous by
the theorem that we proved.
But you don't have to
just look at polynomials.
For example-- so for
example, the function f of x
equals 1 over 3 plus
sine x to the 4th.
This is also continuous--
is a continuous function.
Why?
Because for all x-- first
off, 3 plus sine x to the 4,
this is never 0.
So this function makes
perfectly good sense.
So the bottom is
always non-zero.
Sine x is continuous, so sine
x to the 4 is continuous.
3 is a continuous function.
It's just a constant.
So the bottom as a function
on its own is continuous.
And 1 over that
function is continuous
as long as the bottom is
never 0, which it's never 0,
so again, by this theorem here.
So we used the composition one
to say that sine x to the 4
is continuous.
And we use that one,
the theorem before that,
to show that 1 over 3 plus
sine x 4 is continuous.
So let me write
this out real quick.
I will say by
composition theorem,
the function sine x
of 4 is continuous,
which implies by, I'll
say, algebraic theorem,
meaning that theorem that
involves algebraic operations,
3 plus sine x to
the 4 is continuous.
And by the algebraic
theorem again,
since 3 plus sine x to the 4
is never 0 for all x and r,
this is continuous.
All right.
So next time, we'll
look at some properties
of continuous functions, namely
called the min and max theorems
for continuous functions.
So the great thing about
continuous functions
is if you look at them on
closed and bounded intervals,
they always attain a maximum
and minimum at some point--
not just that the graph
is bounded above or below,
but there's actual point
where f reaches that min
and reaches that max.
And then we'll also prove the
intermediate value theorem,
which says between any two--
if I have a continuous
function on an interval a, b,
and I look at f of a and f
of b, and I take a number
in between those two
values, f of a and f of b,
there exists a point
in between them
so that f attains that value.
And this is extremely important.
And we'll definitely
see why later once we
get to differentiability
and continuity.